[Musique]
je vais vous raconter une histoire qui
nous vient du pérou il était une fois un
lama caca d'oie
oui je vous sens un peu perdue l'a
écouté ne vous inquiétez pas je vais
vous raconter d'abord d'où vient cette
histoire
[Musique]
de thé près de trente ans maintenant je
suis comédien et conteur beaucoup pour
les enfants aussi pour les adultes
et puis voilà ça m'a emmené sur les
routes
et tout ça est arrivé jusqu'au mois de
mars 2020 ou là j'ai dû arrêter de me
promener pour raconter mes histoires
[Musique]
cette stat temporel m'a permis d'écrire
les histoires voilà j'ai eu du temps
beaucoup de temps
la première qui est sorti de ce petit
cerveau c'est le lama caca d'oie tout de
suite quand j'ai écrit cette histoire
j'ai eu envie de proposer à l'inde mais
fidèle ami avec lequel je joue des
spectacles qui est illustrateur et
auteur de bandes dessinées qui s'appelle
olivier supiot les chars je le suis où
il veut parce que j'ai une confiance
totale en lui et c'est vrai que sur les
comptes dessinée on est allé un petit
peu partout dans différents endroits
dans le monde
richard est sur scène il raconte les
histoires il n'essaie pas de la lecture
il est vraiment en mode compte à côté de
richard ya un écran où sont projetées
les images que je dessine où on voit le
dessin qui se fait en direct donc
lassay-les-châteaux d'accord donc il
retourne à wellington leurs pêcheurs
rentrer chez lui
et là effectivement quand ils y arrivent
la petite maison a disparu et est la
place se dresse un grand et beau château
avec des tours un pont-levis des
drapeaux c'est bien j'ai le temps
nouvelles et voilà j'ai le temps même si
ça fait vraiment qu'une silhouette tout
on voit quand même un pnj nato après il
sera mieux que ça là c'est vrai que tu
veux que j'élargisse à un peu forte et
plus le temps de faire des châteaux un
petit peu plus mais pas beaucoup plus
faut que je sois plus simple une fois
que j'ai achevé l'écriture du texte
pendant donc le le premier confinement
j'ai fait un premier prêt découpage un
peu grossier
quand il m'a de madiba oui écoute
pourquoi par après j'ai travaillé sur un
découpage plus précis mais la balle à
moi en tant qu'auteur je me transforme
en enfants de 5 6 ans tous les jours
vers 18 heures je recevais une
illustration en couleurs et en plus
c'est nous qui les a envoyés dans
l'ordre wen lors voilà donc l'histoire
apparaissez voilà au fur et à mesure
montre moi un petit peu tu es petite
recherche d'un bon au départ c'était pas
ça tu voyais c'est un petit peu un petit
peu de guingois fès un petit peu en
arrière
mais il était parce que presque plus
réaliste voit sa taille serrée trouver
un truc plus un peu plus en plus tout
mais quand même un peu plus enfantin et
forcément au mois par rapport à ce que
j'avais imaginé
quand
quand j'ai écrit ça alors je me
retrouvais et puis en même temps et ça
c'est un peu et ça c'est un peu agaçant
aussi c'est qu'à chaque fois les
illustrateurs bonifie ce qu'on écrit
toujours à chaque fois ils vont amener
le petit truc en plus bas on n'y avait
pas pensé on n'avait pas on avait voilà
ils amènent leurs pattes
leur univers
[Musique]
il ya le fait que vu qu'on se connaît
très bien qu'il ya un côté un peu comme
des gamins qui font des bêtises tu vois
c'est à habas tiens t'es cap tépacap il
a ce côté un petit peu car sa tenue et
regarde tu as vu la tête que j'ai fait
aux personnages est pareil lui avec les
mots ils utilisent certains mots où il
s'amuse avec les mots pour que ça
rebondisse
voilà c'est cela ce n'est pas sans
émotion que je t'amène le troisième cas
existent mais je préfère que tu
découvres et plus que tout de suite tu
te fasses des petites images
ouais ça marche voilà ça au canada ça me
libère
ah oui si tu veux je te connais un peu
un abat un laveur à sa venue il ya
quand même aussi ce côté où on s'amuse
enfin je veux dire on peut pas on ne
peut pas comme quand on fait les comptes
illustré on ne peut pas envisager sa
queue
j'allais dire que mon travail c'est
quand même du travail c'est difficile à
dire mais c'est du travail mais il ya
quand même cette joie de faire quelque
chose et s'amuser à le faire bon
maintenant vous savez tout je peux donc
vous raconter mon histoire
cela m'a donc s'appeler pedro il adorait
marcher dans la campagne manger l'herbe
grasse
rien ne semblait le différencier des
autres lamas sauf que pedro était vert
et il en était très fier